i thought in order to prepare us it
might be good to add some summer sounds
right now even though we're in studio so
maybe we could start with
um those cicadas you know yeah so you
want those 17-year gestating insects
that come up from the ground and make a
really harsh noise no how about that
just that grasshopper okay sure yeah the
chirping of grass the tripping of
grasshoppers i'd like there to be so
let's start with that let's lay that in
do you want do you want to suggest
something
no no you don't have any summer sound
you don't have no summer stuff come on
i i really i don't i don't know when
you're talking about sounds how about
yeah what are you talking about are you
even listening to me clearly here
found out that she neglected to make a
hair appointment yes with i guess this
guru who knows how to do very curly hair
and all of her appointments book up
immediately at the first of the month
they do you found out seconds before we
went on mike
and i think you haven't been listening
to a word i've said because you're
thinking about your curly hair no idea
what's going on i'm sorry i really care
and i want and but i
all i'm thinking about is how i have to
wait so much longer now for what does
she do that you can't get done anywhere
else i'm serious
she just knows curly hair she just knows
how to cut curly hair but no one else
does you can't go to any shmo and be
like can you cut my hair and like
summer's coming up i just got highlights
all i was thinking about was how nice
the new curls would look with the
highlights and now i'm like ugh and
you're talking plus you've got a big
event coming up
yeah i do you've got a big event which
is the christening yes of your two boys
your twins mikey and charlie yeah i will
be at that ceremony you're the godfather
i'm the guy that's the most what yeah
i don't know what i was thinking so i'm
going to wear a ceremonial robe this is
true yeah i'm wearing a ceremonial robe
yeah he is i am i am and i have to say
certain things in armenian yeah and you
just sent me the text today with the
pronunciations yes did you send me a
vocal tract too i did yes so i have to
learn how to say these different things
it is not an easy language it's not it
is not but it's not a lot of stuff that
you have to say but yeah i'm i'm really
sorry i'm not paying attention you did
also did you say chick ate us isn't it
sick
yeah but what if yeah but if it's a girl
it's a chick
what if what they sent you in armenian
is just like you and our meaning saying
i conan o'brien hereby decree all my
properties
yeah yeah that's what she's going to do
sonya has worked it out so that i'm
basically
all of my income and all of my my
holdings are being transferred
to the
yeah
never to be the godfather of these two
children yeah and never to go near them
again
so anyway um sorry i'm sorry i wasn't
paying attention we got some good
information out just with that that was
because you weren't paying attention we
learned that your hair is
very aggressively curly
and it needs a special treatment to be
under i don't know i wouldn't say
aggressively grasshoppers have been
chirping this whole time so if we want
to layer anything or something else in
yeah i would like an owl okay an
occasional owl that'll come in three two
one
sorry that was a hawk hold on three two
one
you probably don't even need to put that
in because there's probably owls where
you live anyway there are owls where we
live yeah okay um but instead of that
owl you know the owls are supposed to be
really smart they're a symbol of wisdom
yeah can you occasionally between the
regular owl sounds can you just add oh
i'm smart i'm smart
that's stupid just occasionally you got
it i'll take that sound back
i'm well educated
and give me the i'm smart again so i
have it clean
i'm smart i'm smart you got it
i'm smart i'm smart how about an
occasional like a bear just rustling
around in the blueberry bushes yeah i'll
put some blueberry bushes in too well
they make a sound this is sort of a
russell russell you got it or just audio
from kurt russell oh i don't care i'm on
a roll
how can you tell that it's a blueberry
bush they have a just you'll see and his
name knows the audio from kurt wilson
i'm gonna do is the one from tombstone
where he goes you tell him i'm coming
for him or whatever it is and i'm
bringing um and he'll come back bring it
in and hell's coming with me you tell
him i'm coming and hell's coming with me
you hear
hell's coming with me
oh god what a great movie
i know you haven't seen him i know tax
really upset about it but i i will okay
i'm gonna i'm doing my best to keep us
on track here it's like hurting uh
kittens one with very curly hair that
needs to cut
um now that you said i need a cut that's
all i can think of you gotta stop
bringing it up well i'm okay
so i am preparing us to be outdoors by
creating in studio we've added some
sounds there we're listening to them
right now
um maybe uh a lone coyote sure
oh do you hear him in the distance i do
spooky
that's cool i should say yes so pasadena
and this will be at night as well yeah
we're doing this starting at seven and
then we'll we're gonna you know record
for a while yeah that's nice tell where
it's at night sure well first of all at
seven in la in the summer there's only
six more hours of daylight so yeah
that's gonna be fantastic
what a great yeah and in pasadena by the
way can i say something it's so hot
pasadena is a frying pan we can start
later if we want it's i looked it's
gonna be 83 that day so around seven
we're probably looking at you know mid
seventies
as my wife says early and late seventies
for temperature she said something like
what's the temperature today it's the
early 70s
wow so as hot as it was when nixon was
in his first term
it's 1971 out there and
that's the late 70s uh what's what's
what's the temperature today watergate
hearings the cars just released their
solo album
it's 1979 it's the late 70s i think um
we've got some nice summer sounds yeah
maybe off in the distance we hear
a hobo
uh blowing into playing his harmonica by
the train tracks that's nice isn't that
nice way way off there's a it's an old
hobo he's
just had his just had a
can of beans yeah and he's uh he lit up
that little piece of a stogie he had yes
that's nice now i am going to put a
moratorium on this because this is a lot
of work for me so yeah well whatever
yeah no sweat off my back hey guys i'm
hesitant to point this out but we're
having a grand old time like just a
bunch of chill chumps hey
well you and i are the chill that's how
this whole thing started yeah kona never
became a chill chum because he's not
chill yeah we were going to try to teach
you how to be a chill chum it's just not
going to happen no it's not maybe over
the next five episodes in the nighttime
eastern l.a pasadena
sunset with the cicadas chirping in the
fire crackling no i don't know i
think that what makes this work if it
does work at all i don't know this
mixture is
you two are
just wildly satisfied with yourselves
yeah and um i'm not i always think i
could improve um there's more to do on
this earth we have limited amount of
time oh so you were saying wildly
satisfied in a negative way take it how
you will i was taking it in a very
positive way so that's what a children
would do because we're content with who
we are yeah we're secure with ourselves
we're not like oh we you know we need to
be better
nor do we need to phrase things
efficiently or effectively no just
probably
we don't care
um
i got you back chill chum cece
always always now the chill chums this
will take the place
these episodes will take the place for a
while the fan episodes are correct yeah
so you won't be hearing the fan episodes
but we will get back to those
because my life's blood is talking to
people who are excited about conan
o'brien
and being trapped in the wilderness of
pasadena with two people who got over me
long before they even met me
is my idea
is my idea of an absolute hell